N
REPUBLICAN ANATHATER OWN
BELECTIIT THEACKS FOR
R ROGE SENDING OUTA L SAYING
QUOTE, PERSONALLY I THINLD BE I
RINE.OROU YOUR SIX.OFEMBERS OF
D OF SUPERVISORS
TAOUS
ACTULSO RECEIVEDS
ORANGE PRISO
MAIL TODFTT
THAT EMAILLING FORM "OUTFRONT" N
MARICOPASUPERVISORS.
THANOR,
'V DEALING WITH THIS
THR
HAVE BEEN RECEIVG ESPECIALLY
YH,NATELY, THE
THREATS CONTINUE AND THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE G DR ATE
ARIZONA STATE SEND OTHERROSS COS
TOTHE BO                       S
US TO NDING HERKER  C
BEUSTANDING UP AGA T
ELECTIONISICING NOWY THE COUNTYS
YIBPTRD SUPPORTERS
E  FOR, LET ME
PLAY THI
>> THEY DON'T UROUTERS.
GIVE
WHY ARE THESONER T ROUTER?
>> WE'LL PULL THE CAPTURES OUT
OF THE ROUTERS AND HAVE A CYBER
Y IS.
COMPUTERWH
HE ATTACKING.HIISBA
THEORY.
OND ITN SATELLITES
WERE UTILIZED TOS
FROM TRUMP TO BIDEN.
CAN E AND R ALL
WHAT KT THESE
ROUTERS?
SOUNDS EVEN CRAZYHE W WHAT YOT.
YEAH, SO  IS TH
THIS ALL COMES DON OF WHETHER T2
WEED TO THE TED
R  AND ESE WERE NOT HEF
NTERNET.
FROM THE ARIZONA STATE SENAT IF
WHAT THEY WEGSSTE VER TOTIH
FORWARD NGRS.
BASICALLY WOULOVBLUEPRINGO
MA COUNTY.ION
THAT AN ISSUE?
ON -- ON FL
, , IF THIS GO
T WOE
INFORMONSITIVE L
ENT ACTITIW FOEM COULDPUE OPER K
IT'S NOT JUSRICOPA
BECAUSE WE SHAREAT
A
STLITERALLY
THREATEN SENSITIVE LAW
ACROSTHE STATE OF ARIZOERE
TO TURN THESROUTERS OVER.
FI.BTILL, THE THREAT